men who don't work out are like women
who cry on Tick Tock after their pet
bunny dies it's disordered weak and hard
to look at
when women are pregnant they eat for two
when my female friends are pregnant I
drink for two as I will today on this
episode of the yes or no game with my
friend
Candace Owens now before we get to my
guest
you've got to order this game the Yes or
no game is available right now daily
wire.com shop you can test your
knowledge of your friends and loved ones
up to nine players all sorts of
questions covering every single topic
dailywire.com slash shop and now I will
figure out
which of my friend and loved one knows
the other one better right now
it's going to be forthcoming I am a sore
loser
yeah I believe it the results are not
that I went but you're gonna have one
advantage which is
I think this is non-alcoholic Oh I
thought you're going to say people will
be understanding because I'm pregnant
yeah no that's that's true also but I I
think it's non-alcoholic otherwise
your baby number three will just have a
lovely time
do you know the rules I know the rules
okay yes and you know that's how I feel
too yeah you know ladies go first okay
should we take the first card okay do I
read this out loud yeah okay good
Princess Diana's death was an accident
such a good one who does this such a
good one because it's so obvious
okay ready you know you take mine what I
think you're gonna say one two three
awful convenient that tunnel in Paris
and
awful convenient did I get your guess
right no you think it was an accident
I'm like the biggest conspiracies but
like I actually think that one might
have just been an accident is it just
because you're friends with the Windsors
oh no yeah it's just Prince Philip's
gone you don't need to protect him
it's weird you know what it is I think I
haven't looked into that one enough but
and I just have memories when I was a
kid of that happening and everyone being
like it was an accident and I just
accepted the truth yeah accepted that
the mainstream media was telling me to
truth yeah they would never lie to you
they would never lie and the thing is
her her continued existence only
threatened the last major monarchy in
the west right so is that the theory
well
I don't know she was you know it's kind
of weird for your future Queen to be
divorced from the Future King and then
for her to be shacking up with some like
Arab guy I don't know it's just a little
I think the Arab guys Prince Harry's dad
though
now that's a theory I had not heard so
the red hair it's uh it's uh from
Genghis Khan actually yeah it's
recessive okay so now I go
given that they make up only six percent
of the population and are responsible
for 65 percent of all related deaths
pit bulls should be outlawed as pets a
little edgy fellas oh wowgy out there
outlawed as pets
I think about your answer okay let's go
oh wait I go this way
yeah
correct that's correct I would say no
really you don't you're fine with
pimples no no I'm not fine with pimples
at all but I think if you outlaw it
it just brings into question a lot of
other things that we'd have to consider
more deeply and
um I I would say I think people should
not own Pitbulls I am so against people
I think it is ridiculous when people are
like is how many more stories can the
people that said it depends on the owner
then get eaten by the pit bulls yeah
yeah
it's not the owner except the aggressive
dog I am a special I think I would offer
that I do think it should be outlawed
around children like I think when you
have a small child and you have pit bull
it should be outlawed you should not be
allowed to have people this much but
then what if let's say it's just a
single guy I mean he's got a pit bull
he's going to take the dog for a walk
you're going to go to the park yeah well
there's going to be kids but you could
you could
um
well also now if he goes to one of these
Millennial Parks it's just only dogs
it's only Millennials and dogs right
yeah yeah maybe in like certain places
too like in New York City where there's
just like a lot of humans but I guess if
you're like living in Columbia Tennessee
and you've got like 800 acres I mean
what they're going to kill a deer yeah
if you're in the steplands of Central
Asia yeah you could have people yeah but
I I just think it should pick up some
people like I think we should be
responsible enough to stop buying pit
bulls and especially putting them around
small children because truth is they're
just aggressive I mean I just read a
story about one got off the leash and
ran across the street and killed
somebody's dog and then walls them in
his face and just like every there's a
new story and you look at the statistics
and it's like it's telling a story
they're like no it's the owner I'm like
is everybody
everybody's got a Pit Bull is just
training their pit bulls to do these
things right also the thing that they
forget about they're they're
anthropomorphizing dogs in a way that is
only going to get worse as Millennials
treat their dogs as children but dogs
don't have reason so it's true if you
train a dog in a bad way the dog is
going to maybe behave worse than if you
train them in a good way but it's not as
though the dog can reason about abstract
things like justice and the morality of
chomping on a little toddlers something
like that so you just can't you can't
blame the dog right you can't blame the
pit bull when he eats the toddler it
that's his Instinct that's his
especially because as they age all dogs
and cats get ornery anyways yeah you
know what I mean like my cat as she got
older she was just like less tolerant
and like she swiped once never has ever
even hissed at me nothing but then my
baby was born and he was pulling at her
and she just swipes like she's an animal
you know what I mean so our instinct
when something's pulling out her face is
to swipe and I think people are
completely deluded when it comes to
pitbulls did a whole episode on this but
I would stop short of saying to outlaw
saw them because I think there are
probably deeper considerations there
it might be a slippery slope like a
Libertarian kind of thing you just no
you're no libertarian definitely not a
Libertarian I I just I have I have to
think about that one okay all right all
right well I'll drink anyway I don't
know you have a drink it's on yeah I
don't think you know take a little golf
yeah okay
um
so I might have you throw that back up
[Laughter]
all right I'll move your card too wow we
have a nice little discard pile
all right
my team is hotter than your team
it's not taking a lot of thought no this
is for me
I think you would have to agree yeah I
mean do I have eyes yeah exact reason
and the two brain cells to rub together
yeah obviously my team is hotter than
your team who are you going to compare
my I've got I've got Mr Davies and
producers
I've got girls like that was a very easy
one that was a very simple one so if you
get it right do I drink I I always play
by the rule if you get it wrong you have
to drink if you get it right you get
well I'm betting whatever it is a
thousand yeah when you're doing really
well
those are oh okay it's me
I know you so well you do know me so
well listen I'm an open book yeah but
you you're a mystery Raptor even after
all these years either still unless
you're a total lib it's clear that women
should keep it zipped while at church
okay really interesting addiction yeah I
like the way it's being presented I
forgot to bring this back unless you're
unless you're a total lib women should
keep it zipped at church
I would say because of the wording
actually the statement now it's
perfectly right for women to take part
in the solemn high mass in the uh Salve
Regina in some of the chanting and some
of the responses you know
spiritual that's sort of no I'm not they
shouldn't be preaching or doing any of
these parading rituals that's what I was
thinking preaching I know why I would
say Obviously yeah obviously they
shouldn't yeah they should not be
preaching but they speak at all in the
church should they speak at all a wider
questions now in the low mass yeah they
should not but really nobody should yeah
you got me you got me right on that one
okay you got me right on that one but
should they preach absolutely not
absolutely it's just the most absurd
thing ever and it's part of the reason
why
I have a lot of questions about
protestantism with a lot of
a lot of that going on yeah you're on a
journey I'm on a journey
[Laughter]
wasn't there it was a big split with the
Baptists over this there was because one
of the big Baptists out in L.A yeah he
mega church I thought he was a
conservative guy but then he was
promoting priestesses suddenly he said
priestesses are a thing and he
apologized to women and I just thought
to myself this is how we're going to end
up with homosexuals in the church
there's nobody's gonna say I read the
scripture and I've done research and
actually it's totally fine to be a
homosexual and lead a church and it's
going to be part of your friends once
you start seeing how you interpret the
scripture yeah it becomes very
problematic very fast and that is the
reason why Methodist churches are flying
the lgbtq I don't know how many letters
they've attacked on since the flag no
the main line is completely gone my
priest in New York great friend of mine
was an Episcopalian priest he became a
Catholic priest over this Priestess
thing back in the 70s and I said A
friend of mine might might become an
Anglican priest and he said Michael
that's not like rearranging the deck
chairs on the Titanic it's like grabbing
hold as the Titanic goes all the way
down and so all the main line is gone
but I thought the evangelicals and the
Baptists and things like that the low
churches I thought among Protestants I
thought they were doing relatively
better but then yeah all this stuff
starts infecting them too yeah well yeah
to be fair when they had when they took
a vote
uh oh they booted the guy out yeah they
did put him out yeah so there there is
that but there were it wasn't by uh the
margins were not 100 I mean it was
literally like I think I don't know
maybe something like 15 of the churches
voted like yes they should still stay in
and I was like this is a problem like
even the vote is a problem on the basis
of your vote if you voted yes they
should stay in yeah you should be kicked
out and the thing the way the feminists
frame it as unless we have the women
take over all these traditionally male
spaces you're gonna have weak women and
I think a weak women like
um all the great female saints of the
church like uh St Lucie like Teresa of
Avila uh all the all the really strong
modern women present company I'm not
flattering you present company very much
included compared to what some like
shrieky little feminist or something
give me a break well I'm just saying
women in leadership roles in general
whether it's even women casting ballots
and voting
it's almost problematic uh because we
vote emotionally
thank you
currently if going up against the
trumpers the ramaswamy mommies actually
have a better chance of getting their
guy in the White House than the de Sims
do yes or no
in the primary against the trumpers
who does better the Rama Swami mommies
first at first I've heard that term
that's quite liking that or the decepts
the Rama Swami mommy seems kind of nice
the Sim seems not doesn't yeah I didn't
write this that's pretty this is uh
someone has a bio somebody somebody okay
okay
you're putting me over here on your side
you're saying no yes
I know at least I had like you know
generally speaking there's two yeses and
you probably just need one on this table
you only so you're right that's true
yeah you just need one yes for the
designers
so I said
that you would say that the Rama Swami
mommies have a better shot than that
that is correct I would say absolutely
and I you got me right yeah I I think
that the Sims have a better shot than
the Rama Swami laws that the simps are
just the comms team they're not likable
they they it is really actually you
tweeted this I think yesterday tweeted
it like three weeks ago and I just saw
it and I was like their team has
completely crushed his chances and it's
so I didn't believe it was so angry at
the trumpers but they're angry at like
point zero zero zero zero zero one seven
percent of people that are young at them
online yes and they're like basically
making every person that supports Trump
guilty of the sins of maybe four people
that they're fighting online and it's
actually making them lose like that you
they need Trump support it's just
prudentially it's insane I I it's not
that I thought you were wrong when you
made this point it's not I was a little
skeptical because I had never
experienced it firsthand yeah and then
this happened to me yesterday because I
I tweeted out
it was after they all got upset that
Trump said that Xi Jinping is a as an
impressive leader and I said look one
he's just bragging about how he beat an
impressive leader at a trade deal but
two there is a strain of conservatism
that kind of admires Xi Jinping because
he keeps his country in order and
because he uh governs According to some
conception albeit perhaps misguided of
the common good and that's not the
libertarian kind of right-wing stuff but
there is a strain of traditional
conservative thought that kind of
admires strong leaders who who keep
their country together yeah sort of like
people that admire Vladimir Putin we
kind of like the people who say look I
don't like Putin but I admire that he's
done this that or the other thing right
and all of a sudden it's not that I I
was attacked by conservatives randomly
who don't like Xi Jinping it was these
DeSantis accounts I'm not saying they're
being paid by the campaign or anything
but they all have the little alligator
and their accounts that exist basically
just to promote DeSantis and they start
attacking me and I thought
and kind of personally attacking me and
they're probably still doing it and I
thought this is really strange I am not
endorsing in the primary right I praise
Rhonda Santos for something or another
almost every day on my show I have spent
some time with Rhonda Sanders I really
like him I'm I also really like Donald
Trump I had so I think if you're going
after me
the most I'm calling it like I sees it
how many voters are you turning off look
the Trump voters the Trump campaign
doesn't need to worry about this trumps
have 30 points in the polls DeSantis is
down at 20 or less they have to win over
a huge number of trump voters and so if
you're just going to personally
viciously attack it it reflects so
poorly on the candidate even though Ron
DeSantis personally has nothing to do
with this you know it's just a very poor
reflection of of an otherwise I think
that's exactly what I was very even Keel
going into it I I was interested to see
how things played out wasn't committed
to any candidate felt how I felt about
Rhonda Sans I didn't like the way he
kind of entered in yeah you were you
were always skeptical but not enough to
like attack him or say anything was
wrong with him and then his uh Christina
push I was in comms she is quite vicious
and she did you go after she's always
been nice she went after me and it was a
step on your head while you're drowning
go after someone by liking a bunch of
tweets and tweeting like sub tweeting
things to suggest that I was responsible
for what Kanye West said so it was like
you know it was jumping on that but it's
just like okay you are running an
account that says that you represent
present the ideas of of Ron DeSantis
you're just pushing people away right
like if there's not so they do that all
the time though it's not just like she
weighs on issues have nothing to do with
Ron DeSantis but she is the voice for
Ron DeSantis and so when she does that
people assume this must be what Ron
DeSantis thinks about this she shouldn't
do that so that's what I said I said
they thought they had a Kaylee mcanany
who was excellent when she was press
secretary right Sharpshooter but she
didn't speak about things that Trump
wasn't concerned about she so they're
not able to separate their personal
feelings from what Ron's feelings are
and what people are seeing it like
they're reflecting it it's actually
hurting Ron so that's my take on I think
I think their campaign whereas they
pretend to be above it they're like
we're different from Trump or Trump
without the drama no no no they're very
Petty they're very dramatic the vague is
actually the person who is saying above
it all he's just above the phrase he's
not going out it doesn't go after
anybody he just tells you his ideas so
to say this campaign is pretending to be
what a bake actually is and when I have
make on my show I was so impressed I was
so refreshed I really liked him and I
like that he's still even though
obviously he's competing with Trump he
has great reverence for all the things
that Trump has done even when he speaks
about things that Rana says is getting
wrong he's very level it's never
personal just talks about this is what
he's getting wrong in Florida and here's
what I would do differently and so I am
uh I guess are we calling people Rama
Swami Mommy Mommy
it's even the it's not just the
candidates because because DeSantis
doesn't personally attack people really
right no it's but the people everyone
around him and it's interesting because
I hadn't noticed it about uh his
staffers I really was only noticing it
about
like rapid response random accounts
that's interesting Universe influencers
like you guys are all hurting his
campaign you're hurting his campaign
because you look at the the Vivek team
for starters I don't know I mean I know
them in the sense that I'm friends with
Vivek ramaswami and so I kind of if I
were just like an outsider looking at
the campaign I wouldn't know any of
their names and that's probably a good
thing I think it's a good thing yeah I
think it's a good thing he really does
remain above it so I very much like the
bacon I like that people are now
starting to pay attention to him and
listening to his ideas but do you think
okay all of that to say though he's at
whatever you know I think I think he's
going to Eclipse DeSantis do you you
really think that he is just wow I think
he will eventually yeah I think he will
that's okay yeah he's catching something
the Rama Swami mommy just made the
prediction I made an addiction right
here
men who don't work out are like women
who cry on Tick Tock after their pet
bunny dies it's disordered weak and hard
to look at
that's just funny who wrote these cards
I don't know some Philistine probably
okay so men who don't work out are like
women who cry on tick tock I'm gonna
focus on that first part because it's
kind of the second part is it's to sort
of
I have to think about this hold on don't
don't don't do it yet
okay I got mine okay
you certainly got that right
dude I got that right yeah yeah of
course yeah you know how I knew why
because George George is it an
exceptionally good looking man but he
he's not like in the gym he's not some
like Jim bro but he works out every
morning does he he rose so it's just me
yeah you're looking for a friend in this
British yeah he rose every morning at 4
30. he just plays a game of cricket
every single week and then he jumps in
the pool you know he does the ice one
yeah and then he jumps in there and then
he also runs but he doesn't do the like
yeah yeah
no it's a he doesn't no no no no no no
that's very unbritish that is and it's
also my argument as to why these are not
comparable things and why working out is
overrated is
I'd like to think that I'm really really
threat no I'm I'm fit by the standards
of a guy from the 50s okay like I eat a
lot of fatty meats and I drink and I
smoke cigars and I've never seen the
inside of a gym and in the 50s you think
of Superman or I don't know Ricky
Ricardo or just like any guy from the
50s they were all just kind of
like a bit doughy but not they weren't I
think they weren't bad how's it doing
it's a bit anachronistic to do that
because people were just more active in
general because there was less Tech so
whereas now you have to isolate your
Fitness because it's so easy to be lazy
right then you know your grandparents as
you know walked up both the hill both
ways to go to school which is in snow
Yeah in the summer exactly in the summer
yeah all of our grandparents did it we
know this yeah so I always think it's
funny because I think about my
grandfather because he never worked out
yeah but he was always working out like
he was in the yard he was you know what
I mean so he was a very physical whereas
now we live a very sedentary lifestyle
so I think you do have to incorporate
some sort of a fitness but I wouldn't
say a type of woman who cry on Tick Tock
because that's just demonstration
demonstrative of like complete and utter
psychic collapse yeah psychic collapse
yeah which is like that which is not the
same as a man not working out so you can
grow I feel like you would by the way
Yale Oxford like it's kind of right up
the alley
at the end calling out
all right my turn don't
don't okay I'm gonna be really angry
I'm gonna flip a table for no reason
assistant
it's really good
having a Ukraine flag in your bio is
more forgivable than wearing Crocs
been wearing Crocs yeah
this is a tough one for me it's very
very tough for me there's no easy answer
it says there is not an easy answer
right it can be okay it would feel
better because you've said that because
I'm about to cry on Tick Tock to be
honest you're feeling real close to a
cry on Tick Tock and
but I know I'm not allowed to so I
wouldn't do it
but if I could
I've always tried to be kind of moderate
about you know Mr zielinski and all this
but you early on you just said I don't
like the guy I know grifter when I see
one okay highest paid actor in the world
highest to get 100 billion dollars I
mean wearing the fatigues the whole time
put on a different outfits we know that
you're not in the trenches okay go to
the White House please put on it please
show some respect we've sent you
billions and by the way out I've
traveled to Saint Tropez the ukrainians
now have Yachts they've got they've got
shallots in Switzerland they've got
Yasin
here these are our tax dollars but she's
wearing the Army fatigues he can't be
bothered to buy a tux it's like bro you
can buy it you can buy a Tom Ford tux 20
000 times today okay his wife's shopping
at Prada in France I mean I can't stand
it you're right that was the right
answer I'm about to freak out right now
not an easy answer but a simple answer
yeah a very simple answer
there is a topic I would like to debate
Ben Shapiro on
my goodness
absolutely yeah
it would be unpleasant to lose my job
but I don't know I mean you know but it
might be fine that's the thing I guess
the reason it might be a no is a topic
out of ten thousand yeah I know I know I
know what would be your what would be
one topic you know I have to actually
give us all ten thousand we've got it
happily so I would like to brag just a
little bit and pay a compliment to my
friend Ben which is
back in the day years and years ago he
and I we would get into fights all the
time about this physical always physical
always kind of like this they would
always get into fights about political
philosophy
because there are certain thinkers that
I really admire and enjoy that he didn't
like
I'm thinking of people like Michael
oakshot this is a really nerdy fight you
know people like Michael Oaks shot
people like Russell Kirk people like
Edmund Burke and Ben it was very didn't
like him he was he's a John Locke guy
you know he's a more of an Enlightenment
guy and I'm kind of an
anti-enlightenment guy I'm an
anti-liberal guy and I will say this and
this is
so Ben's great credit over the years
he's starting to simp for my guys he's
kind of like an oak shot guy now he's
like definitely kind of a burp guy and
so it's not a debate then it's no debate
it's interesting it's just drinks and
agreement
she would like to drink and agree with
Benjamin I would debate him on vaccines
um
so this is another one though he used to
be super duper Pro like yeah 100 Now
isn't he a little questioning I don't
know I don't think certainly on the
covet backs he is well I know he said he
wouldn't have gotten the covet back yeah
exactly but I don't know about all the
other ones I think that would be super
sure that would be interesting how do we
get that product yeah exactly well I'm
down for that right yeah I'll bring my
Martini exactly
Europe all right this is going to be a
good one
seed oils cause sunburns
since you're an educated person I assume
you know the answer to that
um
I you got this wrong so you're gonna
have to drink and you have to drink a
lot really yeah why what I don't know
anything about seed oils and this was
almost a racist question because I don't
get sunburned so I this is like so I
don't I don't know anything about the
oils you're right I don't get somewhere
so I'm like obviously it's not true
because I've definitely eaten seed oils
and I've never gotten sunburned
so I'm going to do a little Common Sense
here see if this can't be causing wow
you you black people this is the best
argument I've ever heard as to why seed
oils don't yeah absolutely not I I've
consumed a lot of CEOs in my life I've
never gotten a sunburn because I'm black
let me tell you to show me honest point
on this exact point uh my mother my
beloved mother was very dark-skinned
very I'm having an Italian black I've
seen Italian yes
I remember I saw photos of her when she
was young and I when I was a kid I said
oh Mom I didn't know you were black and
I did and even in the Summers and she
smelled Michael anyway but even uh later
on like when I was a kid I get very
Brown in the summer and she would get
black you know and uh
I always thought okay I wouldn't sunburn
but then in the middle of my teen years
for some reason I started sunburning wow
and I thought what now in retrospect I
realized I was consuming a lot of seed
oils and then sweet little Elisa who
follows all the hippie stuff that you
follow she says Mac you guys got no more
seed oils We're not gonna cook with them
we're not going to eat whatever sorry
greatly reducing I was like this is some
hippie dippy mountains
I don't get sunburns anymore
and I'm that calm a little bit of that
olive oil I could burn I don't right
yeah but what are the seed oils in the
reason why I don't want to go everything
is already so crunchy but I'm fearful
that if I let if I look into everybody
keeps telling me they're telling me to
look into it I'm like guys you don't
understand I will go crazy like I will
be a psycho I know I will just bite onto
it like a pitbull yes like a pitbull on
a tasty toddler yes right
yeah
well you're there Candice because you
can't turn away from the truth when you
see it
no I'm already like an 82 year old full
Grandma right now and if I struggling
with them every little I know how I am
all right fine
you're gonna no it's gonna be single it
and six minutes later I'm gonna be done
you're gonna be done I know I can no
longer avoid it it's following me uh I'm
easy to work with
so this is we would this is how I think
you would answer about yourself
and you're answering how I would answer
about myself okay
ready
absolutely correct
and I say you would say that you are not
easy to work with
Savannah Savannah
[Laughter]
me off when I say something like that
she doesn't get over here get it
I would say I'm easier to work with in
George I actually do I'm I'm I'm I think
okay I'm I'm easy to work with I have to
really think about this I don't know
what I would say just drink anyways I'm
gonna choose yeah because yeah you
should just drink for me yeah drink
again because I think what I would say
is I I think I'm very easy to work with
because you know why no one ever leaves
my team so that's got to be you know
usually you get a high turnover you're
not usually work with but I would say
that when it comes to my show I'm a
perfectionist and so I'm I mean down to
like naming the titles all the stuff I'm
very involved that if something's not
right then somebody like is slipping
that day and I'm like listen I write the
show I go like you got to do this job
and you gotta do it right and I will
like
yeah so but I think that's a that's just
like everyone has to bring their eggs
but it's not easy like I think about it
with Jeremy too is it Jeremy easy to
work with Jeremy is he that's gonna
sound like I'm being too nice please
don't tell Jeremy I said this Jeremy is
a joy to work with it's the joy of my
professional life to work with Jeremy
he's the guy's a creative genius it's
every day is something new it's just on
he's not easy to work with I mean same
thing he's
he he's got this crazy vision and he's
ruthlessly perfectionist about
everything and so it's not easy but it's
very gratifying and I see a kind of a
similar yeah I would say I'm super nice
to everyone that I know people will say
over and over again so I'm not I'm
definitely not mean I never raise my
voice I don't believe in yelling I think
actually when you yell at people it
shows you've lost control yeah but you
do believe in Corporal partnership but I
hit them you hit that I do because
Savannah you do but that's different
that's different people get it just for
recreation yeah okay uh my turn you're
up
you are definitely easy to work with I
am yeah I'm just such a you're like
whatever huh get it turn it in on don't
turn it in
oh this is so great
most likely Savannah will be fired
before Ben Davis
brilliant timing on this
you know the
the sharpness of that question might
change my answer
[Music]
one two three
no
it can never be too sure no no I and I'd
like to make this announcement oh right
now
I've enjoyed working with Ben Davies and
I appreciate his contributions to my
show but I I think it's time for him to
move on yeah I do I do too yeah but I
was just about to say about Savannah so
she just got to speak really but I have
enjoyed her you're gonna lose them both
I feel free now because you can just say
whatever we want now Mr Davey's already
wrote the rest of my questions so I
don't need him until the next episode
brilliant and timing
okay you're up
if you're not married by 30 you should
only really be concerned if you're a
woman
one two three
drink my dear oh yeah oh my gosh you
would say no explain because people are
going to start to wonder about you first
of all if you're a man and they're going
to wonder about your loafers and the
heaviness or lightness of them but the
other thing you should be concerned
forget about how people perceive you
because you know I think there's it's
perfectly fine to
obviously engage in religious life you
know join an order or even consecrated
singlehood or something like that but
if you lack the charism for celibacy
and you're single by 30 and you're a
fella you are very likely going to be
fornicating or looking at porn are you I
mean men it's like we're riding around
on an elephant the libido is so insane
and even more I know women you know sort
of throw themselves at me as I'm walking
down the street but it's not like women
have no idea for men the sexual drive is
just so intense that if you're single
and you don't really have an outlet for
that and you're in your 20 late 20s 30.
it's not going to be conducive to your
virtue okay but what was the question
you should be concerned you should only
be concerned if you're a woman okay so
it's how you think about what concern is
okay that's an interesting take on it
because what I would say is that I heard
that question and thought women
biological clock ticking you should be
concerned you haven't found a partner
you know you've got a very short Runway
now is figured out and also I had this
ex-boyfriend actually dated a guy and
the reason why I was going to say I
disagree about 30 is because women like
older men so they're not like running
out of time there's no biological clock
that's ticking it's like are you going
to figure your ish out yes or no who
knows but you're not like oh well that's
it it's over for me right I have this
ex-boyfriend who I dated who was 11
years older than me I was 22 who's 33.
right wow and he said something to me
that he sometimes use a sentence your
life you just never forget it right and
you know at the time we were dating and
I was like you know why don't you date
any girls your age and he's like well
because if I date a girl that's 33 she's
going to want to ring immediately and
and he said and the truth is is that if
you're a guy and you meet a girl and
she's in her early 30s and no other guy
wanted her your first thought process is
what's wrong with her what am I missing
wow and I never left me it never left me
oh man you know and I I've asked a few
guys that question and they've been like
to be honest like yeah if I'm at a 33
year old girl and everything looked
right and I would be like okay but what
am I missing you're so great yeah that
like why didn't some other guy swoop you
up in your 20s and so I think that it's
a steeper climb for women for a lot of
different reasons not I'm obviously it
has worked people I know people have
gotten married 36 like it can happen but
those I think are the exceptions and not
the rules
um do you wonder though if not because I
I totally get that in principle but now
for women especially Millennial women
who are raised in this feminist culture
that said don't get married just pursue
the widget Factory career forever and
just do you you and then these women
come to their senses in their late 20s
and early 30s and they're otherwise
great women who were basically just
duped by culture I mean I wonder I think
that's a pretty large chunk these days
yeah feminism can colonize your brain I
say it all the time in my show I'm like
don't like Kyle you will get to 30 and
then you get to 33 and it's first it's
I'm having fun living life I'm doing me
and then suddenly realize all your
friends are getting married all your
friends are having children you're
seeing all these announcements on
Instagram and you're like what was I
thinking you probably also walked away
from a really good guy who liked you at
least once yeah at least one maybe two
in your 20s but you just thought that it
was going to be forever your youth was
going to be forever and there is
actually a biological change that
happens and I tell him in this the whole
time like I remember being in my early
20s and I had the young Carefree
mentality I was also uh liberal in my
all my perspectives so I was eating up
the feminist garbage which is fine I
always say you can experiment with
feminists like a drug in college it's
fine
you shouldn't be proud you try the drug
and then you gotta let it go you know
um but yeah so I had these feminist
perspectives and but then something
changed and it wasn't Amendment it
wasn't a mental change it was deeper
than that it was like biological
spiritual suddenly you're aware that you
are a mammal and I would say it happened
around 27 2016 when I was like must find
mate have babies like it's so weird and
I'm seeing it happen to other women now
that I'm friends with and they're
turning 27 28 and they're like must find
mate had babies so there is something
that happens there's a sea change that
happens within women in their later 20s
where suddenly all of the ideology means
nothing the sociology means nothing and
the biology overrides you're like give
me baby yeah when I met George I said I
want kids like I mean it was the first
date you know your first uh yeah and you
said uh hello nice to meet you George
give me baby yeah give me baby right now
yeah yeah and he we're married we're
happily married exactly absolutely
I was gonna put my all my crazy up front
and it worked it did for people who
don't know 18 days 18 days to meet my
husband and before we got engaged and I
got it right
you did get it right yeah you're so cute
cute
angry Englishman yes yeah he's very he's
very manly he's a very British cute
uh
I'm up Candace is up yell's been babe
fire him I thought so I'm glad we I'm
glad he didn't leave yes nobody listens
to us around here
the law of attraction is harmless and is
simply a vapid Instagram level therapy
practiced among redheads women who drink
from Stan Lee's and dudes named Skyler
Vivid
uh
read the first part
the law of attraction is harmless
and is simply a vapid Instagram level
therapy practice among redheads
women who drink Stanley's and dudes
named Skyler what's a stamp oh my God
it's like the basic white girl cup that
everyone has sometimes these things
happen on Tick Tock where like and then
like white girls go crazy like we'll
have to do it right now and it was a
Stanley Cup and some girl was like I
drink so much water when I drink out of
this cup and then literally yeah every
every white girl in America bought the
cup yeah I have for like and it's like
75 I have seen white girls it's got a
little handle yeah they're like it's
true it works I drink so much water just
to give a little white girl try this is
actually really sweet
you think I'm gonna say you're gonna say
no
and I'm certainly going to say no
harmless
simply
I agree of course I agree
right you're right because it's
it is it is all the things in the second
part of the question it's the law of
attraction is just for
depressed but eccentric women to try to
make sense of a world that they find
chaotic and confusing but it's a cult
it's a cult it's new age occultism and
it will
drive you crazy and it Dr and the women
who go into it go completely inside no I
totally agree I totally agree that the
ones that cry on Tick Tock yeah they do
with their families
75 they paid for that that's so
outrageous if these things happen no no
no I wanted to see if I could get Mark
safe from sun sun burns from Stanley
Cups
Europe I'm up
I've met someone who I believe was
possessed by a demon oh my goodness
okay
got it
correct I'm not sure why because I just
I I felt no for you yeah because I just
thought you see the good in everybody so
even if you there was a demon you're
like you know maybe they just had a bad
day maybe it was merely a vacation
maybe it wasn't time
yeah that's right yeah I don't I I'm not
confident even if people who've had
bizarre uh aspects to them
I'm not confident I I think oddly enough
people knock me because they say that I
talk about demons and angels and stuff
too much but I don't see demons under
every Rock I think it's I think demonic
possession is a
basically rare thing maybe increasingly
prominent in our culture but it's not
every person who has a problem is
possessed by a demon they might be
attempted or effects but yeah I think it
full-on possession is still pretty rare
I think Hollywood is quite demonic yeah
and and I see people possessed by it in
a weird way that I've been like I've
seen people ruin their lives and on this
quest for Hollywood level Fame and I
think that that's a demon that got you
and they can't shake it it's really
weird to watch someone destroy it so if
not like a demon literally acting
through their body yeah at the very
least a demon influencing right oh yeah
yeah you think Hollywood is where you've
seen it yeah it's very demonic I think
and then there's just there's Pathways
to it like Instagram I've seen women
like I think it's a possession of sorts
and maybe it's not yeah like a full-on
demon but to see the way that Instagram
think about the way that we grew up we
were like playing outside and we have
like scrapes on our knees and I had
braces and I was super ugly but I
thought I was cute in my braces
well look like a pictures and I'm like
oh my God I thought it was so cute and I
think everyone else thought I was cute
too when I was getting my braces changed
different colors I thought that was hot
and I smiled big in my middle school
pics because I wanted people to see my
teal braces
I would do a smile like this
I thought I was fly in my braces maybe
you were all the confidence in the world
and then I see these girls today and
they're getting like lip injections at
14. because they're spending so much
time on Instagram and they're seeing
that's a something's not right there and
it willing to go under an entire the
knife these are possessions of sorts
right like and so whether it's demonic
true to being a demon I don't know it
probably isn't right but the people are
possessed and social media causes I
think possessions yeah and it leads you
down those paths I mean especially when
people dabble in drugs especially the
mind-altering drugs and when people fall
into these crazy sins of Pride that
really takes you down a bad path the
but I've heard stories of first-hand
accounts of people who
like are speaking to people and then
they'll start yelling an Aramaic kind of
like that degree yeah but even that is
increasing in prevalence I've spoken to
exorcists who is talking to an exorcist
is sometimes it's sort of like talking
to a plumber
you think you're going to hear some
amazing wild story from an exorcist
often it's just yeah well then I had to
unplug this person you know they had
this stupid demon flying around them and
but the stories I hear from them are
pretty wild and she tells me that yeah
yeah George George chats with these
people yeah and not the demons right not
the demons I don't I don't think so not
anymore not anymore we've put that
behind us but talking to exorcists now
they say the phone rings more often
today than it used to yeah there's yeah
there's something going on you can feel
in the climate and definitely within
Hollywood and it's it's programming
people in a way that I think is I just
have questions about it yeah I agree I
agree especially Hollywood Gamora by the
Sea uh-huh
yes drink drink am I up or is it you me
it's you okay I'm totally lose track
I want to find the person who's writing
these remind me to do that after Pfizer
is more trustworthy than Carly Russell
don't even I'm obsessed yeah with the
Carly Russell I'm upset I don't I don't
even all I've seen about it is from you
yeah okay just stop then because you
just need to understand so you can
actually answer this question like this
black girl goes missing and like they
find her running car she calls 911 says
there's a toddler on the side of the
road right and then
um she handed the phone call reports the
toddler and the toddler kind of looks
like Tommy Pickles wearing a t-shirt and
a diaper she hangs up the phone and then
she calls her sister-in-law and she's
like talking to her like I'm gonna try
to talk to the toddler she gets out of
the car just started a lot he just
scream police got there five minutes
later Carly's wig is on the side of the
road this is in Alabama okay we're
waiting outside of the road her purse
her her uh Keys her Apple watch and the
car is running and obviously this is on
the side of a like I 495 in Alabama it's
like a busy kind of a busy road and
um
so there's this Manhunt ensues for 49
hours for the toddler and Carly you know
and because they only found the top the
the wig rather they they only found the
way not her keys they didn't find her
right and so of course it's just
instantly you were condemned if you were
white and you were not talking about
this because the reason why I don't know
the story is because you're racist
that's right if you didn't share a story
you try to get her it's because black
girls don't get any love long story
short she turns out 49 hours later at
her parents house and she's in like a
catatonic State and she won't talk to
the police but you know so there's this
like a long way to figure out what
happened and they're going why aren't
you telling us like where the toddler is
like she's just like there her family's
like leave us alone she needs to heal
mentally and that was instantly like
this is Jesse's Molly yeah whoa and it
ended up being worse than Jesse smell it
as in like she snatched her own wig she
told the police a story that like some
guy with red balding hair Prince Harry
type character took her into the woods
it's kind of been him but he's not
strong enough they were over a fan put
it right in into 18 wheeler fed her
Cheez-Its I mean you gotta get it it is
like like she makes Jesse smell it look
like Child's Play and you know what you
know why Candice the only reason we were
talking about this is because you're a
race I know and then they did that then
they switched and they said you better
talk about it and then if you started
talking about it within seven hours they
were like how dare you have any
questions
it is a glorious story it's like you
cannot miss it because it's better than
just you smell it and it's so the
question is
is Pfizer more credible than this person
yes
yes yeah man at least she didn't poison
them I know
the day I trust Harley was so more than
I trust Pfizer
obviously easy easy
I've cried in the past year in the past
year
actually we'll need to Define oh okay
got it what did you define cry
I personally feel like you cried this
morning I well it depends how you so you
did I cry I did because I thought I have
the joy of drinking with Candace today
there's tears of joy no I I have cried
you know deaths in the family kind of
thing but not but is it a cry if you
because I feel that the way I cried was
very manly yeah and the way I cried is
the way a man ought to cry which is you
know at the moment of intense you know
you're at the funeral or something and
this loved one is is uh you know being
sent off
you kind of let a you know one or two
yeah just like uh yes but it's but you
hold it it's not like you know like
Johnny Fontaine and The Godfather I
don't know you know it's just like you
kind of let the one you kind of you
don't even kind of just wipe it away
like that so I've done that I've done
that but I haven't started bawling
them in the last year no balling no
balling you weren't like only
b-a-l-l-i-n apostrophe I'm falling all
the time but I have not been bawling yes
I actually can think of one time in the
past year that I was I'm not a big crier
but she even think is weird but I just I
don't cry a lot you're pretty tough uh
yeah but I boohoo boohoo cried and it
was just way too much stress going on in
my life I think in October where uh I
mean it was just a month where I think
Savannah and I traveled 26 days to 30
days we had the Kanye controversy going
on the documentary was coming out
Savannah literally almost died in Paris
like of an allergic reaction and I just
remember and then I got home don't
forget I was postpartum and then all my
hair started falling out at the same
time because you know you get like
postpartum shedding yeah yeah and I just
remember like I was in the shower and
like I would the hair yeah I was holding
in my hands and it was like throwing all
this oh my God
women take that very hard so I was like
please what's so weird
absolutely that was a tough month
obviously but
with every woman takes that so hard but
it's a natural thing it's a natural
thing but they all start crying yeah I
think for me it was just like if it had
just happened by itself you might have
without like Kanye West anti-Semitism
Scandal George Floyd documentary coming
out like everything that was had
Savannah literally almost dying in Paris
and I just was like I was like I can
take nothing else and then I take a
shower in my hair and I was like
cried about myself in the shower and
that's the only time I can think of in
the last year where I like properly boo
who cried yeah and it was nice I get why
people like to cry cathartic that's nice
it was cathartic and I felt better after
no I didn't because my hair was still in
my head it's still gone
it's fine yeah and my daughter's really
cute Louise is really cute my
goddaughter absolutely she is a very
cute both of your children are just yeah
yeah she's so sweet Georgina but he's
Georgie is a tough tough little guy
Georgie I'm scared of him yes because
he's already like he's such a guy yeah
he's already like riding motorcycles is
the thing he's very everyone says oh
Montreal is very Advanced your children
both of them are very Advanced he told
me to build him a house yesterday and I
was like that's not a normal sentence
from a two-year-old like I said don't
hate your sister just said no build me a
house and I pointed at the end I was
like this is I'm not that's not a nurse
I don't have the tools in the sheds but
I didn't ask you if it was normal I mean
now get the building
so two year olds are crazy we all know
that we're terrorists I'll drink anyway
yeah you drink because I cried and I
lost my hair nobody was there for me I'm
up I haven't remembered a single one and
I've had like four sips of this martini
it's worse to be skinny fat than gym
thick
okay I got mine
uh
correct correct yeah for sure yeah for
sure totally I think it's better it's a
cope for the gym thick Bros who are
trying to say otherwise but no you know
I know I think it's better to be gym
thick so you're wrong drink up what yeah
because then you're at least you know
you're in shape what you know whereas if
you're skinny fat then you're not you're
not strong okay you're strong I'd like
to point out that both the father of
your children and the Godfather of your
daughter are neither of us are Jim thick
Bros
yeah but Jim they could also be for
girls
actually I don't know but I made you
drink anyways you did that's fine now
I'm getting thicker by this point yeah
going to the dentist is pointless and
fake much like recycling or taking
women's studies in college I'm just
gonna leave your cup right there
smile
I feel like you're a dentist bro
you are a dentist bro
Candace
I could not tell you the last time I
went to the dentist oh my God now I do
use I use a very fancy toothbrush do you
so that it stays it's like relatively
white even with all the cigars and the
coffee and it's they stay relatively
yeah yeah I don't do you know smile when
I asked you to smile so that was like
well I didn't want to give it away yeah
uh do you know the only time that I
would go to the dentist
2 30.
2 30. does that mean 2 30. oh my gosh
dad jokes
drink for that happily it's two to
Thirty okay I actually you got this
right you did get this right I did yeah
you're not so deep let me see I do you
have actually beautiful because I love
the orthodontist the ortho but how do
they say so white I have an obsession
with the orthodontist why I'm such a
brushing my teeth I actually have a
mental Dental disorder like I think I I
am constantly trying to perfect my teeth
I goes to the orthodontist they're
excellent too I love my orthodontist
thank you
still wear my braces this kind of goes
back to seventh grade when I thought my
braces were cool I just I I haven't a
thing an affinity for the orthodontist
you want to hear a secret I've never
said the center I wear my retainer every
night I wear my retainer every day and
Michael and says that I have a problem
she's like why are you wearing a
retainers I swear and I was just like it
just makes me feel safe by the way if
you take it out for like two nights
your teeth move around I know that's the
whole even still I know so so I actually
thinking about getting a metal bar in
the back of my bottom row because
everyone has I I it's like body
modification the point is is if all the
Metro Stores to have many to choose from
today a mental Dental disorder was okay
I think my orthodontist is tired of
seeing me yeah like I can't fix I can't
fix it I can't I mostly see 11 year olds
I'm like I'm like Candace you're not you
do wow
and your flaws oh I floss like a psycho
wow yeah I love it I floss sort of
annually
I think the tobacco and the alcohol I
think they're meant to be an Englishman
yeah it's just get to Rowan and you'll
be all right yeah uh you're right
a night of drinking and smoking with the
boys is a healthy practice for married
men you would agree with that
no I know you would agree with
me I know I would be shocked at what you
know that I but
guys need their guide time thank you 100
I I felt 50 50 actually it's like what
George tells me when he comes back after
you guys go to the Cigar Lounge he tells
what you guys talk about I'm like I'm so
glad you talked to McDonald's about that
because I just don't want to talk I have
no interest I know could it be less
interested in what you and Michael
almost talked about a wonderful
conversation about this
it is my entire social life
my entire like go out social life is
going to the Cigar Lounge with your
husband
and maybe like one other guy or two
other guys yeah the same same for my
husband yes and like he needs that and
in the same way that women need their
girl time and because women talk we talk
about really stupid things so I'm so
compelled by political topics and
whatever the Dilemma is of the day but I
also need to talk about really stupid
basic things with my girlfriends which
is I find fascinating because I'm like
okay there's so much more than this why
do you care about this ridiculous
Scandal and I'm like no no no no no this
is everything and it's not everything I
know it's not everything and I'm very
practical but I'm still a woman it's
pleasurable and you yeah because it's
like it's relaxing women like to gossip
I mean it really goes back to hunters
and gatherers men I mean it's just it's
different because legitimately
over the countless hours and countless
cigars and drinks with with your husband
specifically
we've almost entirely talked about like
routing the saracens out of Jerusalem
yeah
it's a fun talk yeah you know and and
that's just not fun that's not relaxing
to me yeah well you guys just engaging
your brains for fun whereas like women
I'm impressed he'll be oh I hope like I
saw Michael and it's giving you an
example of when you guys had your last
kid oh and Alyssa's pregnant again I'm
like oh is it a boy or girl he's like
who I didn't ask
I'm like what kind of information like
how are you not interested enough to ask
these basic questions he's like I don't
know men are just different I had that
exact same conversation when I came back
and I mentioned to Elisa that you for
the first time now in in after two
children we're off track yeah to keep up
and I said oh yeah you know Candace is
pretty shoes oh wow that's oh that's so
wonderful she said oh man it's a
wonderful man well did you enjoy what
like
I'm not supposed to know that
unbelievable I don't know how you guys
do this I'm like I'm like George what do
you mean you don't want you didn't ask
this question
I'm glad you're you know I'm glad you're
like yeah men and women just doesn't
work the same our interests are just
buried that's true uh
I'm up you're up I get the last one I
got the last one
not being white helped my career
okay so I would now your answer is as me
yeah and I'm answering but you are white
I'm very confused not being what so if
if that is your premise
then uh you're going to have to answer a
certain way but okay so I
not being white has helped my career
canvas
how could you be so foolish what I eat
but you are white Candice
the
Sicilians are a racially liminal people
they're very marginal and back look in
my wayward youth I made a number of
mistakes
one of which was I was briefly a
professional actor
and I did this little parts and TV shows
and movies and things like that please
now they classify you when you're an
actor are you white are you black are
you or are you ethnically ambiguous
now I having a little bit so I'm a
little lighter right now
in California was darker hmm when you're
a little ethnically ambiguous one time I
got I got a great this was the uh this
was the job that got me eligible for sag
The Screen Actors Guild
which is a terrible Union actually
I got to play the white part
and the Hispanic part wow because I was
ethnically ambiguous and
putting my wayward youth my
indiscretions of my past aside I think
about my actual life and career
I I actually believe
being a little bit darker has allowed me
to be a little bit edgier when I talk
about certain topics if you were Irish
looking for Irish Nordic I think I
actually if I were really waspy looking
I don't think I'd get away with it so if
you looked like George George I would
not get away with that I could carry
Thor's hammer around I would not be able
to opine the the Mediterraneans and the
darker you know this in popular culture
the Italians get away with a lot more
yeah they deal with crime yeah that's
true lewdness obscenity no it's true
they do it is it is a minority yes it's
kind of a minority also you guys were
treated like absolute dirt when you got
we were actually never talked about that
I'm like if you want to talk about like
people that should be upset about things
that happened in yesteryear the Italians
you were treated like dogs when they got
here numbers wise the Italians were not
the most also Irish Irish did not apply
do you know the the largest mass
lynching in American history no I don't
the Italians 11 Italians in New Orleans
wow that's a very fun fact that is and
people nobody knows it now you know it
wasn't like numbers wise I would say
probably black people were the majority
of lynchings but largest it was the
Italians a lot of people everybody can
claim a little bit of historical
oppression okay so why did you pick yes
for me well because you have this you
know you have this great ability which
is you come out right compliment me you
can I will you come out and you're in
this culture you didn't choose to be in
this culture but you're in this culture
that says
if you're black you've got to be a big
lib and we'll reward you for being a big
lib by the way but you got to be a big
lib and uh you'll be the this advantaged
uh ethnic background and why people are
terrible and just go along with us and
then you come out and you say uh no
actually that's all a bunch of BS and
here's why it's BS and especially in the
early part of your career you just kind
of laid it out flat and so you were
punished for that initially by the
mainstream but I think you were
ultimately rewarded because it just it
put you in this position where you
uniquely were listened to you uniquely
were hated you uniquely were threatened
you uniquely were but it it blew you up
into the mainstream yeah where now you
can talk about every moment too because
it was people were just so much more
vicious I think because they were like
how it's one thing to say you're black
conservative but how could you support
Trump this one of them yeah I mean how
could you how could you be look there
are plenty of black conservatives but
you're kind of you're you're a real
conservative right I'm also very vocal
which I always say Dr Ben Carson who was
so sweet when I met him and he's like
he's been able to do so much more in
terms of communicating your ideas than I
was throughout my career and obviously
he's a literal brain surgeon he's
obviously much more brilliant than I am
he I am do you remember at the debate I
said what's your what's the thing you're
proud of stuff and everyone said oh I
beat this Democrat or whatever and he
goes I separated conjoined twins
casual same
but he and I remember saying to him is
because you were way too polite you know
and I think that's the difference is
there's a certain decorum to like Dr Ben
Carson and Dr Condoleezza Rice and
they're just sort of like I'm not going
to engage when they get called in Uncle
Tom and a and I'm just like no I'm
I'm here and I'm willing to engage like
I will 100 get into an argue with
somebody I think that that sort of
startled people because typically black
conservatives were just shut down you
know when they said something it was
like you're a Trader a race Trader or
whatever and people were like okay you
also did this thing which
it just means you took the opportunity
it does this doesn't have to do with
your race but it means you took the
opportunity where a lot of times someone
becomes I'm the black conservative
they'll just stay there in that little
box and you said well I don't know I'll
talk about race sometimes but I have
many more things to say yeah and so you
even kind of you kind of beat them at
that game or you said no I'm actually
I'm going to talk about uh vaccines I'm
going to talk about religion I'm going
to talk about this I'm going to talk
about Trump I'm going to talk about that
I'm going to talk about foreign policy
Russia I'm going to talk and it just
totally
yeah I actually haven't sent an article
what somebody wrote and they called my
topics on my podcast podcast the Unholy
conservative gumbo I quite like that he
was just meant to be insulting and I was
like and you it's actually a really
funny article but I agree there's no
question that but I always question in
my head I'm like what if I did it as a
liberal like what if I was Candace Owens
and I was yeah George Floyd dies I'm
front and center I'm doing the media
circuit at MSNBC and CNN I'm debating
Michael Knowles right talking about how
amazing Greta thundberg is and how they
environment you don't care about the
environment because you don't have to
breathe the same air black people have
to breathe whatever yeah I think I would
have you'd be richer I'd be richer the
deals think about it what they would
have given to me look at Van Jones yeah
freaking freaking Jeff Bezos for no
reason gave him 30 million dollars I
would be so much richer and that's what
I tell people I'm like if I was a
liberal I would have done it so much
better than you so much better
because it paid I'm like girl if I
wanted to make money all I had to do was
say black lives matter and be the same
Candace Owens
was it go after conservatives would have
a good time it would have helped your
crushed Matt Walsh she would have
destroyed him that would have been a
great adventure yeah it if you had done
that your career would have benefited
materially and in the short term yeah
your soul would have been destroyed yeah
uh Candace to your health to your child
I'll drink for the two of us
the pleasure as always we'll see you
next time and I'll see you
[Music]
thank you